[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants bush
waouh pas trop d'accord mon gros
nounours tu leur montre le livre et moi
je leur en raconte l'histoire
mon agent bonsoir
qu'est ce que tu attends que vous avez
froid qui n'ont peut-être pas très
maligne bidon c'est un livre qui dit
merci
c'est la suite d'une histoire que vous
aimez beaucoup c'est ce qu'on sait moins
c'est un [ __ ] de yangshe nicolas
exactement les enfants là on s'assoit
mais nous possédons pas comme ça là
sale gueule
à vous pas trop aujourd'hui bien que fut
notre petit chinois est au bord de la
rivière avec son âne et a mis dix ans il
a apporté du bois de la peinture de la
toile blanche et à ramasser des roseaux
et du bambou pour quoi faire maintenant
tétouan icône arrache les enfants
écoutent le sud avec les planches de
bois et les roseaux il fabrique un beau
bateau ensuite il prend la toile blanche
l'attend sur des perches en bambou est
en fait une grande voile qu'il place sur
le bateau
et quand il est terminé et en tue le
pain le laisse sécher au soleil et une
fois qu'il est bien sec notre petit
chinois et des paris en le met à l'eau
et voilà le beau bateau de yang chu qui
flotte ainsi je sais faire débat tant
thyssen ours
oui mais sont pas aussi beau que celui
jiangxi le petit chinois et son âne sont
très fiers de leur travail
m'ayant que j'suis fatigué et il se
repose à l'ombre d'un cerisier et
s'endort
quand tout à coup au le petit âne rêver
yang jiechi
car le gros gros vilain est au bord de
l'eau et essaie d'attraper le bateau
villa je suis las personas j'ai pour ce
que vous êtes bavard alors mais
heureusement leurs amis le poisson
volant est là et il tourne tourne autour
de la tête de ce vilain très vite vite
et gros vilain petit canard
pourquoi donc j'ai eu ressent bateau aux
propos sur le continent non le petit
chinois ne prend pas son bâton car gros
vilain et bien puni j'ai tombé à billets
dans l'eau et tout mouillé se finit yang
chut je te promets je ne recommencerai
plus est notre gros vilain part se
cacher tous auteurs derrière un arbre
c'est bien faire les voleurs sont
toujours le zorro par cette revue docks
de vos lieux ayant le chu accompagné de
dix ans par faire sur la rivière un
grand tour en bateau guidés par leurs
amis
le poisson volant qui leur montre le
chemin
le bol d'or l'histoire fut elle était
très jolie cette histoire merci
marchande samm allons lui petit ou tout
haut
[Musique]
bonne nuit le petit ange la jettent à la
ligue 2
en une annonce à demain tenus nicolas
connu quand on aime
[Musique]
bogny petit pape rhône elle bonne nuit
petit nicolas bonne nuit tous les
enfants allaient sagement vous coucher
et faites de beaux rêves faute boureux
nous voilà patron alors en route mon
cher nos noces dans la nuit à demain
auto body
[Musique]